Berlin avenue Unter
Linden traduisez poétiquement sous
lestig voici la relève de la garde au
monument dédié à la mémoire des victimes
fasme démonstration de militarisme
prussien pour le plaisir non non
affirmation d'une souveraineté qui a 25
ans cette armée populaire impeccable
sans doute l'une des meilleures du monde
est pour la RDA la gardienne de la
patrie
socialiste
K
si vous deviez en quelques mots
esquisser le chemin parcouru pendant ces
25 années comment le feriez-vous il a
été extrêmement difficile extrêmement
difficile mais ça a valu la peine de le
faire comment
dire la République démocratique
allemande en 49 c'était presque zéro ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui chacun peut s'en
rendre compte c'est déjà un bon bon bout
de chemin qui a été fait en 25 ans je
dirais même que un très grand bout de
chemin qui était par je crois qu'il faut
ajouter aussi que nous avons accompli
une révolution vraiment vraiment une
révolution ici dans ce
pays bien de de devenir un pays
socialiste c'est pas si facile même dans
les conditions données en
49 je crois c'est c'est très important
de le constater aujourd'hui end avec
beaucoup de satisfaction je un bon bout
de chemin dans la
conscience de ses habitants surtout sur
le plan économique naturellement mais
aussi dans la conscience des citoyens de
ce
pays la conscience des gens c'est un
capital à ne pas laisser dormir rien
n'est laissé au
hasard est une chose que la RDA déteste
c'est bien l'aventurisme
dans la ville il y a donc de temps en
temps des vigiles des
témoins des panneaux pour glorifier les
meilleurs de ceux qui construisent le
socialisme de ceux qui construisent par
exemple ce palais de la
République Berlin Est pardon ici l' dit
Berlin capitale de la RDA a bien changé
en disant l'effort a été consid
précis planifié efficace les ruines ont
reculé en cercle concentrique du centre
à la périphérie jusqu'à disparaître
parfois un sourire une décontraction
tranquille mais rarement
débridé toujours un ordonnancement tracé
au cord d'au de la façade du socialisme
est allemand de l'autre côté à porté de
jumelles c'est Berlin ouest on touche
avec les yeux car ici l' ne confond pas
détente et relâchement
idéologiques nous avons depuis longtemps
déjà voulu ces accords nous avons tout
fait pour arriver à une normalisation
des relations avec la République
fédérale allemande comme avec tous les
autres États européens d'ailleurs
maintenant dire aujourd'hui que nous
sommes arrivés au bout de cette
évolution au bout de ce chemin ce serait
vraiment être
euh je peux pas dire optimiste mais il
reste encore beaucoup de choses à faire
pour améliorer encore les relations pour
normaliser ces rapports qui disonsle
franchement ont peut-être un an ou 2 ans
juste à peine maintenant il y a beaucoup
de choses qui restent à faire d'ailleurs
raison
pour qui qui pourrait empêcher à ce
qu'on développe davantage encore les
relations des relations norm entretat
d'état à état entre la République
démocratique allemande et la République
fédérale signe des temps les Allemands
de l'Ouest viennent parfois visiter le
monument dédié au soldats de l'Armée
rouge tombé lors de la prise de Berlin
en
1945 mais en dépit de la détente et les
accords pour la RDA les choses sont bien
claires il y a deux États allemands
différents sans aucun lien privilégié
sans relation spéciale la séparation
reste totale pour mémoire seulement oui
il est là bien là le
mur ainsi va la coexistence d'autres
touristes venus des pays socialistes
cette fois viennent contempler de loin à
Berlin est la porte de Brandebourg jadis
saint de la réunification aujourd'hui
gardienne du respect des frontières
d'accord pour le bon voisinage mais
chacun chez
soi